In the next few videos, we'll
be using a data set published
by the United States Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services
to practice creating CART models
to predict health care cost.
We unfortunately can't
use the D2Hawkeye data
due to privacy issues.
The data set we'll
be using instead,
ClaimsData.csv, is structured to
represent a sample of patients
in the Medicare
program, which provides
health insurance to
Americans aged 65 and older,
as well as some younger
people with certain medical
conditions.
To protect the privacy
of patients represented
in this publicly available
data set, a number of steps
are performed to
anonymize the data.
So we would need to retrain
the models we develop
in this lecture on
de-anonymized data
if we wanted to apply our
models in the real world.
Let's start by reading
our data set into R
and taking a look
at its structure.
We'll call our data
set Claims, and we'll
use the read.csv function
to read in the data file
ClaimsData.csv.
Make sure to navigate to the
directory on your computer
containing the file
ClaimsData.csv first.
Now let's take a look at the
structure of our data frame
using the str function.
The observations represent
a 1% random sample
of Medicare
beneficiaries, limited
to those still alive
at the end of 2008.
Our independent
variables are from 2008,
and we will be
predicting cost in 2009.
Our independent variables
are the patient's age
in years at the end of 2008, and
then several binary variables
indicating whether or
not the patient had
diagnosis codes for
a particular disease
or related disorder in 2008:
alzheimers, arthritis, cancer,
chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease, or copd, depression,
diabetes, heart.failure,
ischemic heart disease,
or ihd, kidney disease,
osteoporosis, and stroke.
Each of these variables will
take value 1 if the patient had
a diagnosis code for the
particular disease and value 0
otherwise.
Reimbursement2008
is the total amount
of Medicare reimbursements
for this patient in 2008.
And reimbursement2009
is the total value
of all Medicare reimbursements
for the patient in 2009.
Bucket2008 is the cost bucket
the patient fell into in 2008,
and bucket2009 is
the cost bucket
the patient fell into in 2009.
These cost buckets are defined
using the thresholds determined
by D2Hawkeye.
So the first cost
bucket contains patients
with costs less than $3,000,
the second cost bucket
contains patients with costs
between $3,000 and $8,000,
and so on.
We can verify that the number
of patients in each cost bucket
has the same
structure as what we
saw for D2Hawkeye by computing
the percentage of patients
in each cost bucket.
So we'll create a table
of the variable bucket2009
and divide by the number
of rows in Claims.
This gives the
percentage of patients
in each of the cost buckets.
The first cost bucket has
almost 70% of the patients.
The second cost bucket has
about 20% of the patients.
And the remaining 10% are split
between the final three cost
buckets.
So the vast majority of patients
in this data set have low cost.
Our goal will be to predict the
cost bucket the patient fell
into in 2009 using a CART model.
But before we
build our model, we
need to split our data into a
training set and a testing set.
So we'll load the
package caTools,
and then we'll set
our random seed to 88
so that we all get
the same split.
And we'll use the
sample.split function,
where our dependent variable
is Claims$bucket2009,
and we'll set our
SplitRatio to be 0.6.
So we'll put 60% of the
data in the training set.
We'll call our training
set ClaimsTrain,
and we'll take the
observations of Claims
for which spl is
exactly equal to TRUE.
And our testing set will
be called ClaimsTest,
where we'll take the
observations of Claims
for which spl is
exactly equal to FALSE.
Now that our data set is ready,
we'll see in the next video
how a smart baseline
method would perform.